-A lot of people are watching
right now.
I think it would be helpful
if you guys would introduce
yourself to the world.
A lot of people are watching
"The Tonight Show."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
Go ahead.
-Hi.
My name is RM.
I'm the leader and kind of like
a translator for this group.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hello, I'm --
Where do I dance? I'm Jin.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi.
I'm Suga.
Nice to meet you guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love you!
-I'm your hope, you're my hope,
I'm J-Hope.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi, guys.
Hi, Jimmy.
-Hi, buddy.
-My name is V.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
-Jimin!
-Here we go. My man.
Here we go.
Come on.
Jimin!
Drumroll! Drumroll.
[ Drumroll ]
Drumroll!
-Hey, Jimmy!
-Yeah!
-I'm Jimin!
Yeah!
Yay!
[ Both laugh ]
-Dude, that's what
I'm talking about right there.
Welcome, and last,
but definitely not least.
-Okay. Hi.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm Jungkook.
Nice to meet you guys.
-Yeah, that's right.
Good to see you, buddy.
♪♪
It's been so fun
and exciting having you here
in New York City,
and you got to speak at the U.N.
-Yeah.
-What was that like?
Was that amazing?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You know, I was like --
I was, like, so nervous.
-Really?
-Yeah.
I'm holding up the paper.
-And if you see that,
I was, like, shaking.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Of course. It's a big deal.
-Yes, it was a big deal.
-But what is your message?
What is the BTS message?
-It's about speaking yourself.
-Yeah. What is speak yourself?
-Yeah. It's like --
It's mainly
about speaking yourself
instead of letting other people
speak for you,
'cause to truly know ourselves,
it's important to firstly know
who I am
and, you know, where I'm from
and what my name is
and what my voice is,
kind of like that.
-Good for you.
That's fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Have you been having fun
in New York City?
-Yeah!
-Really?
-Of course.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What are the highlights?
Any highlights in New York?
-I love SoHo.
I want to go there for shopping.
-Really?
-Yeah. Shopping!
Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-That's how you shop?
-Yeah.
-Jimmy!
-That's how you shop?
-I love MoMa museum.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh.
-Uh, New York strip.
New York view.
On my way to work
in the morning,
New York street hot dogs.
Perfect.
-Wow.
Tell me.
You spoke at the U.N.
You sold out Citi Field
in under 10 minutes.
I mean, this is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is a big deal for you guys.
-It's a big deal.
-What do you want to accomplish?
What's next?
What do you want to do?
-[ Speaking Korean ]
You know, want to stay humble
and enjoy the ride,
but I think Suga wants
to say something.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Go. Let's Go.
-Uh...
-Yeah, Yoon-gi!
-Go to Grammys.
-Yoon-gi!
-Go to Grammy?
-Go to Grammy.
-Grammy?
-He said Grammy.
Oh, wow. All right.
All right.
We can make that happen.
Dude, we can call them
right now.
Let's make it happen.
-We can just, like, dream, so...
We can dream, so...
-You can dream. Absolutely.
Dude, #BTSgrammy right now.
Let's make this happen.
-Hey, guys, we're here with BTS.
And we're gonna try out
the Fortnite Dance Challenge.
You guys up for it?
-Uh-huh.
-Let's go!
♪♪
-Oh, yo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Perfect!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Let's go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Yee-ha!
-Whoo-hoo!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are you okay?
Are you okay?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now BTS is gonna show me
the Idol dance.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-1, 2, 3, 4...
-...5, 6, 7, 8.
-Here we go. Ready?
-5, 6, 7, 8!
-♪ Oh-oh, ooh-oh, hey! ♪
♪ Oh-oh, ooh-oh, ooh-oh ♪
-I'm in! I'm in the band!
I'm in the band! Let's go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Our guests tonight -- one of the
biggest groups on the planet.
Their new album, "Map
of the Soul: 7," is out now.
BTS right here!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
-Hey. BTS!
-Ohhh!
-Okay.
Sit down.
-Welcome to the
New York City subway.
What do you think?
First impression.
-Hot dog, coffee.
New Yorkers, like,
scarfing, like,
"I'm so busy for the business,"
and you know...
-Really?
-Yeah.
-I love the movie "Home Alone."
-"Home Alone."
-Yeah.
-"Home Alone"?
-That's a classic.
That's a classic in Korea.
-No. "Home Alone"?
-Aaah!
You know the face?
-Macaulay Culkin? Really?
-Yeah.
-How has it been
coming to the United States
and having people respond
to your music?
-I love you, Army.
-Are you surprised
with how big it became?
-Yeah. Of course.
Like he said,
we came from a small isle,
in a small country from Asia.
So I think, you know, we can
prove that someone from, like,
outside could be
in the mainstream.
So I think that's why we feel
so happy.
-When you see Americans
sing your songs,
what does that mean to you?
Who is the hammiest
out of all of you guys?
-Um...
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, um...
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Okay. Yeah.
-Easy, easy.
-You guys swept the MAMAs.
You won Album, Icon, Song,
and Artist of the Year.
I presented it to you guys.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I was so excited.
-It was special.
-That's crazy, right?
-Because of you.
-What did your family think?
-She knows you.
-Mom. I love Mom. I love Mom.
[ Laughter ]
Before BTS existed,
what did you want to be?
-Businessman.
-No.
-Study hard and go into a --
you know, get a nice job.
That's my dream.
[ Laughs ]
That was.
-V, what about you?
-Saxophonist.
-Saxophonist?
Like here?
The saxophone?
-Yeah.
-Do we have a saxophone?
What was the -- George Michael.
What's that?
[ All vocalizing
"Careless Whisper" ]
♪♪
J-Hope, without BTS,
what would you be?
-Tennis player.
-Tennis?
-Yeah.
-Ha!
-Hyah!
-Ho!
-Oh!
-Yeah.
-Out of three teams.
-Three teams. Three teams.
-He got bronze.
-Jin, how about you?
-I'm actor.
-You want to be an actor?
-Yeah.
Aah!
-No, no.
You can't don't do "Home Alone."
Already did that.
Jungkook, how about you?
-My dream was pro gamer.
-Pro gamer.
-A gamer?
-Yeah.
-Jimin, what would you do?
Host a talk show?
-Oh, maybe.
-Don't take my job.
Don't take my job.
-Oh!
-Jimin Fallon.
-Jimin Fallon?
Suga, if not for BTS,
what would you do?
-Producer or songwriter.
-Oh, really?
First impressions -- What did
you think of each other
when you first got together?
-I saw RM.
-Yeah.
-And then I thought --
-What did you think of him?
-He was amazing.
-Oh, thank you.
But Jungkook --
When I first saw him,
I was only wearing
the underwear.
-Yeah.
-Wait. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa. What?
You were only wearing underwear?
-I mean in the house.
In my home.
-What?
-He came, like,
"Oh, I'm the new member."
I was, like,
only wearing panties and...
Yeah.
That was the first impression.
-So, who put this together?
You?
-No. I was just, like, the first
member for this group and --
-You were?
-Yeah.
-Number two?
-Three.
-Who's three?
-Suga, you came in.
What happened?
How did you hear?
-We were boys.
[ Laughs ]
-Did you ever think BTS
would become this big?
-No.
-Never.
-When you doubted yourself,
what got you
to the next level of like,
"Hey, I can do this"?
Do you remember the first time
you ever performed
in front of a crowd,
and what was that like?
-It was our debut showcase.
Uh, there were about 200
to 300 people.
-300 people.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Now you have billions of people
watching.
But 300 people meant a lot
to you, right?
-Right. Of course.
-I still can never forget it.
Everything happened so fast,
and it was overwhelming.
-It was.
-Yeah.
-And I cried after the show.
-You did?
-Yeah.
-Everyone cried.
-Everyone cried?
-Yes.
-Yeah, because it's a big thing.
"Map of the Soul: 7" is out now.
Yo!
-Yo!
-What is the significance
behind the 7?
-You know, it's a lucky number,
of course.
Yeah.
Seven members.
It's been seven years
since we've been together.
-Wow. Seven. Seven.
It's good luck.
-Yeah, 7-7-7,
so it's like a jackpot.
-Jackpot!
-Like jackpot!
-Ding, ding!
-Jackpot!
-So it's very important.
So, like, we just want to put
the number,
like, as our title of the album,
so, like, that's why.
-The lead single is "On."
-Mm-hmm.
-What does that represent?
-We've been having
our reboots, so, like,
our second single was "N.O."
You know what I mean?
So, like, it's a reverse
of "N.O."
It's like "On."
And "On" represents, like,
you know, like, "bring it on."
Like, so we admit our shadows
and, you know, the honors
at the same time.
We could stumble time to time.
You know, we've been through
all these paths
with shadows and lights
at the same time,
but we admit all of it,
and, you know, bring it on
and bring the pain and we're
gonna stand it, and -- Yeah.
-What is it about your music
that you think fans
are attracted to?
♪♪
All right, guys, if you're
in New York, you have to go
to the greatest place to eat,
and that is Katz's Deli.
That's where we are.
It's the best food.
It's been around
for many generations.
-How old is here?
-I'll let Jake, the owner,
talk to you about this.
Jake?
-Hi!
-Hey!
-Hey, hey, guys.
How is everything?
Welcome, guys.
So, we've been here 132 years.
-Ooh!
-Yeah.
We're known for, like, pastrami,
corned beef,
brisket, turkey,
matzo-ball soup.
We're gonna feed the crap
out of you.
Can I say that? I don't know
if I'm allowed to say that.
-Yeah.
Absolutely, you can say that.
Also, have you ever seen
"When Harry Met Sally"?
-No.
-You've never seen that?
-"Harry Met Sally"?
-There's a famous scene
in that movie.
-That's from this restaurant,
so it's in that movie.
This is the famous place,
the one and only Katz's.
Let's get some food.
Let's do it!
Yay!
[ Indistinct conversations ]
-Whoa!
-Very heavy.
-What's this?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Is it for, like, one man or...
-Yeah, yeah. That's yours.
-Okay.
-In America, this is what
we eat for breakfast.
-Don't let me stop you.
Let's go. Dig in.
Don't be shy.
-Look at that!
-You're good.
-Pastrami?
-Pastrami.
-But no veggies?
-No veggies.
No. Are you kidding me?
No.
[ Indistinct conversations ]
What do you think?
-Mmm!
-So put some mustard on those.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No ketchup.
-No ketchup?
-Get out of here.
Get out of here with ketchup.
[ Laughter ]
-What is the go-to food
in Korea?
-Spicy fried chicken.
-What if you're, like,
late at night
and you feel like having
a snack?
-Chicken!
-Chicken is the way to go.
-Chicken and beer.
[ Laughter ]
Chicken and beer.
-Cheers.
-Chicken and beer.
-Guys, you know
what I want to do?
Let's make some sandwiches and
give it to the people out there.
Let's go.
♪♪
-Okay. So I need your help
making these sandwiches.
I need you
on waiter-service duty.
-Any advice how to cut this?
-Yeah.
You got to use the back
of the knife, like that.
Nice, beautiful...
-Oh!
-Beautiful pieces of meat
like that, right?
So we got some sandwiches here.
-[ Laughs ]
-Thank you.
-When these are ready,
just yell, "Order up."
-Order up.
-And then you come, you grab it,
and you book it.
-Order up!
[ Indistinct shouting ]
♪♪
-Corned beef sandwich.
BTS made it for you.
Hey! Hey!
What's happenin'?
-Order up!
[ Shouting continues ]
-I'm coming! I'm coming!
I'm coming! I'm coming!
[ Shouting continues ]
From me and BTS.
Please enjoy.
♪♪
-Jimmy!
Jimmy!
♪♪
-Good work.
You have a great fan base.
BTS Army is fantastic.
I have questions from your fans.
-Mm.
-Ohh.
-Beats.
-Beats?
-A track.
-The instrumental.
-Really?
-Yeah.
It always comes first.
-Melody or --
some melody or rap.
-Yeah.
-So first the track,
then you write the lyrics
and figure it out.
-What is the black bean noodle
incident?
-Yeah.
-[ Laughing ]
-I had a stomachache, so...
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-How long did you go away?
-Um, I don't know.
Like three or four minutes.
That's not that long.
And I was like, "Um, get me
noodles as fast as you can,"
And, you know, it was just...
Swallowed it and --
Yeah. Boom.
-Is there any audience
that you want to grab
that you haven't got
the opportunity to meet yet?
-John Cena.
-John Cena?
-We want to see him.
He's a big fan of us, and...
We're the big fan, and, like --
-Really?
-Mutually. Of course!
-He likes J-Hope.
-Yeah. He loves J-Hope.
-John Cena.
-Yeah, we were always watching,
like, WWE,
like, when we were like,
you know, 13...
-John Cena!
[ All vocalizing them music ]
♪♪
-Yeah.
-All right.
I'm gonna get you hooked up
with John Cena.
I'm gonna make sure it happens.
All right.
This one says...
-Turn on the YouTube.
Search "BTS Jimmy Fallon."
-Yes.
-Watch the show.
And then you'll be in our Army,
maybe.
-So, you're performing later.
Is there something you do
before every performance?
Can you show me?
-You want to do it together?
-I'll do it with you.
-Okay.
-Come here.
-So...we go down.
We don't go up.
So we'll go down.
And when I say...
[ Speaking Korean ]
And you guys say...
-[ Speaking Korean ]
-You say...
[ Speaking Korean ]
-[ Speaking Korean ]
-Yeah.
-When I say...
[ Speaking Korean ]
you say...[ Speaking Korean ]
Okay? And we go down.
[ Speaking Korean ]
-[ Speaking Korean ]
-Yeah!
-Oh, come on!